hardest part about change is not making
the same Choice as you did the day
before and the moment you decide to no
longer think the same way make the same
Choice act the same way create the same
experience or live by the same emotion
it's going to feel uncomfortable and the
moment you feel uncomfortable you just
stepped into the river of change now
most people the moment they feel
uncomfortable they return back to the
familiar state of the Mind and Body they
start thinking the same way acting the
same way feeling the same way and they
say this feels right now in fact that
feels familiar now going from the old
self to the new self that void that
place of uncertainty that unknown is the
perfect place to create it and if you
and I can become comfortable in that
unknown and begin to decide who we do
want to be in other words many people
say when they're in that unknown I can't
predict my future this doesn't feel
right well the best way to predict your
future is to create it not in the known
but in the unknown so what if you said
now what thoughts do I want to fire and
wire what behaviors do I want to
demonstrate and if you were to close
your eyes and begin to think about how
you were going to act the mere Act of
mentally rehearsing who you're going to
be begins to install the neurological
circuits in your brain to look like the
experience has already occurred now what
that means is that the brain is Prime in
its circuitry to no longer be living in
the past but now living in the future
your great life is on the other side of
you doing uncomfortable things think
about where you want to go think about
who you want to be what you want to
accomplish the life that you want if you
if you paused and took a few moments to
think about who do you want to become
and what do you want to do
chances are it's way different than what
you're doing right now
because if it was pretty close to what
you're doing right now it's not
inspiring it's not motivating it's not
it's not big enough growth it's too easy
to go off accomplish what you want is
difficult it's hard it's scary
and so to become that person it's going
to require you to shed your skin a whole
bunch of times it's going to require you
to go from the caterpillar to the
butterfly it's going to require a lot of
change a lot of growth a lot of
opportunity and inside of that we're
often afraid we're afraid we're afraid
that we're not good enough we're afraid
we're not going to make it we're afraid
we're going to fail we're afraid we're
going to disappoint people we're afraid
that people will judge us if afraid
people are going to laugh at us we're
afraid we're afraid you're afraid you're
afraid of going after your thing
and it's totally normal
but
that change is required
for you to get to where you want to go
it's absolutely required
I look at
what I've done on YouTube and the growth
and the people I've met and
some of the people that I've I've hung
out with and now I coach and mentor on
YouTube and how they can be better are
people that I I look up to and still do
look up to mentors Heroes of mine and me
constantly feeling like I'm not good
enough and I don't belong here and how
did I get here
but the world that I want to create
imagine my my ambition is I want to
solve the world's biggest problem that
people don't believe in themselves
enough I'm never going to solve that
problem right it's never going to happen
and I wake up every day trying to solve
that problem and make it happen and for
me to actually go off and have as big a
dent in that problem as possible is I
need to I need to get better I need to
believe on myself I need to push harder
I need to be more courageous I need to
be more bold
and when I come up against the scary
difficult hard things that it's a sign
that I need to go and do it and say yes
in one of my goals you know I just came
back from Napa where I'm hanging out
with my um my Mastermind it's a pretty
high level Mastermind Brenda Bouchard
and Mel Robbins and Dean graziosi and
Jay shetting all these people
one of my goals is to move faster on
things
as fast as I move on things I want to
move faster on things you know again to
go from idea to action that you get an
idea boom you do something but idea
action idea action idea action and and
bigger ideas and bigger action
it's one of my it's one of my ambitions
because
you know time is limited you don't have
infinite time to solve these problems
and to accomplish your dreams and make
progress happen and I don't want to look
back in 10 years and say man I wish I
just how was I just more bold why wasn't
I more Brave why didn't I just push a
little bit harder a little bit faster a
little bit further I could have I could
have done more why didn't I do it
because I was afraid because I was
afraid of the growth
so here are some of the things that I'm
using to make it tactical like how do
you actually do it it's a great
motivational awesome but how do you
actually do it how do you actually stay
consistent on it how do you actually be
strategic about it I'm going to give you
a couple actual steps you can follow
Beyond just the the motivation okay step
number one is to watch your language and
come up with some trigger words so for
me the scary difficult hard are trigger
words
if I say those things if I feel those
things if I write those things if I text
those things if I if I'm thinking those
things and I can catch it scary
difficult hard are the ones for me then
I have to do it
so if I say oh yeah I could do that but
it's too hard
you said it I said hi now I have to do
it I love to do that but it's too scary
oh I said it now I have to go do it
right what are your trigger words if you
know like think about what's the voice
in your head that when you want to do
something
that it the voice in your head shuts you
down from it
like why can't you go off and accomplish
your goals what are you telling yourself
what's the story and then try to catch
those words that whenever you say those
things again now you have to go take
action on the thing even if it doesn't
work out just because
it's scary for you so you know in Napa
Mel Robbins and I went to do a hot air
balloon ride we're both afraid of
heights
uh we're both you know mildly panicking
getting in there uh
but we did it because it's hard
now that may not seem like a big deal
for you you know the hotter balloon
rides are fun exhilarating beautiful yes
and you know for someone who's really
afraid of heights it's super scary
and I want to teach myself that I do
scary things
has scary difficult heart so I went off
and did it and Mel did it and we were
high-fiving and having a blast and I
don't know that I'll you know now go do
it every weekend but but to show myself
that I can do it this is how you start
to raise your standards and become the
person that you know you're capable of
becoming by pushing those boundaries by
growing and stepping into
the uncomfortable not that I don't think
you have to be comfortable in the
uncomfortable the whole point is that
it's uncomfortable but it's the
willingness to be courageous enough to
step into it so one what are your
trigger words what's what do you tell
yourself that you buy your own story
and so you don't do it so I'm often
giving advice to people and they say oh
that's that's cool but it's hard like
okay but you do hard things
when did you accept hard as a good
enough reason for you not to take action
it happens a lot I tell somebody here's
here's the advice I follow
well that's that's really hard
okay it's it's simple but it's not easy
accomplishing your goals is not going to
be easy you do hard things stop
accepting hard as a reason for you not
to chase down your goals what when did
hard be a good enough reason for you are
you only gonna do the easy things in
life
we've accepted this it's not it's not
even somebody else it's you telling
yourself that you're not capable so one
what are the trigger words what are the
stories you're telling yourself and
anytime it comes up you're doing it
you're doing it just to show yourself
that you do difficult things
two is the boom boom boom test so
that's when your heart's going boom boom
boom boom boom boom
you teach yourself that you do it that's
a it's a physical manifestation a scary
difficult heart is more it's thoughts
it's words it's conscious
where if you feel it in your body it's
going to be more the boom boom boom boom
your hearts your heart's beating boom
boom boom boom boom that's another sign
that you're scared that you're that
something difficult is coming up that
you don't feel like you're capable of
and as long as the intention is good
right like the intention is is good the
intention is to serve the intention like
my heart might go boom boom boom boom of
going to rob this store okay well that's
not a good intention so let's not do
that but most of the things that we're
afraid of are not actually
robbing a store or doing something
stupid it's something that we actually
want to do you're afraid of your dreams
you're afraid of your goals you're
afraid of what that means as much as
it's motivating it's also really scary
so whenever you feel your heart going
boom boom boom boom boom then it's a
sign that you need to go off and do that
thing so Step One is the trigger words
right scary difficult heart are the ones
that fit for you step two is the boom
boom boom boom boom test and step three
I would say is the pillow test and the
pillow test is what do you do every
night before you go to bed you put your
head on the pillow
make yourself proud of yourself
I think ultimately how do you get the
growth that you're after
is doing something today that makes you
proud of the effort that you put in
whether you got the results or not
doesn't matter it's did you put in the
max effort because you keep putting in
your best effort you're going to get
bigger results than you ever dreamed of
so did you put in the best effort that
you did today because that's going to
require you to do those scary things
that force you to grow
and so before you hit your head on the
pillow tonight ask yourself
am I proud of myself am I proud of my
effort am I proud of how I lived today
am I proud of what I did and if not then
you still have time
yeah before you go to sleep
you got five minutes left go do
something what can you do in five
minutes
that would make you proud of at least
how you're ending today
and sets you up for momentum for the
next day
because the more you can pass the pillow
test every day
the more you can feel like today
mattered
the more you're gonna grow the more
you're going to challenge yourself the
more you're gonna
start becoming the person that you want
to be
because you've got big goals Big Dreams
big Ambitions you want to have a big
impact you want to do more than what
you're doing right now you know you're
capable of doing more than you're doing
right now and the only difference
between who you are now
and the person who can accomplish those
things
is your willingness
to be courageous to step up to say yes
and do the difficult things also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
when you start practicing creating that
brain and heart coherence
you can believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that it's actually
there's physical evidence in your brain
to look like it's already happened and
you can begin to understand you can
select a new potential in the quantum
field and every day emotionally Embrace
that future reality to such a degree
that your body begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and you're signaling new
genes and new ways to change your body
to look like it's already happened now
think about this
if there's physical evidence by thought
alone in your brain and body to look
like your wealth or your future has
already happened
it's already happened very happy and
you're already it so it's not about your
wealth it's not about your health it's
not about your freedom it's who you
become so then as you overcome overcome
overcome overcome you become someone
else and so most people don't understand
that oh that the truth is is that every
time you overcome yourself a little bit
more the side effect is that you love
yourself a little bit more we have a
huge frontal lobe and it's 40 of our
entire brain
and most people uh when they have a
thought they just think that that's the
truth and I think one of my greatest
realizations in my own Journey was just
because you have a thought that doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same Choice the same Choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then why is that important because the
more conscious you become of those
unconscious states of Mind and Body the
less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought is not going to slip by your
awareness unchecked because you're it
means to know thyself the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors And the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new Garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable State
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because the person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change and
so we have to unlearn before we relearn
we have to break the habit of the old
self before we reinvent the new South we
have to prune synaptic connections and
Sprout new connections we have to unfire
and unwire and re-fire and rewire we
have to unmerize emotions that are
stored in the body then recondition the
body to a new mind into a new motion
like deprogram and reprogram that's the
act and it's a two-step process
overcoming the old self
allows us to become somebody else and
there is that period of transition yeah
I call it the void where there's just
not a lot happening
and you just got to be able yeah to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop I
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone uh this weekend
broke through to the other side and now
there's so much magic happening around
this person but she's worthy now
to receive it and that's that that is
the key because the universe only gives
us what we think we're worthy of
receiving so we got to come initiated
into this and understand it thousands of
years of programming that says that we
have to change things matter to matter
you know in three-dimensional reality
and it will take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on the stronger the emotion you feel
from some event in your life be it a
betrayal or a trauma or whatever yes the
more altered you feel inside of you the
more you pay attention to the cause
outside of you so the brain takes a
snapshot it freezes an image and
embosses that pattern neurologically in
the brain that's called a memory so we
create long-term memories from strong
emotional events okay so is that true
that I just want to understand the maybe
the larger the event in terms of its
emotion to the stronger of a hold it has
over you yeah well the more it's
embossed in your biology so some certain
people have a strong experience in their
life and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
hour away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back I think
this is a time in history where it's not
enough to know this is a time in history
to know how and if you rewind the tape
10 years ago you know information was
the thing that stimulated thought
stimulated new ideas and and as we learn
new things we make new Connections in
our brains so as we begin to add new
Stitches into that three-dimensional
tapestry in our mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then is
to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it and in 10 years ago
when I went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application it
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself painful yeah
you're going to get uncomfortable right
and
um I think we're in an age of
information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of Technology we
have access to so much content and
information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have Consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change I think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed that old models
old paradigms are beginning to break
down whether it's the medical model or
the religious model the educational
model journalism uh the economy you know
politics it's all beginning to come to
the surface because something else has
to come out and and I think that one of
the things that people are realizing is
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk to do this or a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you just got to understand
the formula and just like any skill or
anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it three types
of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress trauma
accidents injuries false chemical stress
toxins pollutants heavy metals blood
sugar levels viruses bacterias mold and
then there's emotional stress which has
everything to do with raising kids and
and second mortgages and single
parenting and time and and all of those
different elements knock the brain body
out of balance and the emotional
component has always been the
challenging one for most people because
you could be in a constant state of fear
if we teach a person then how to trade
that frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or I
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah we know that okay so let's
take your partner in business or take
your ex let's duct tape them put them in
a cannon and shoot them to the moon now
what are you going to do sooner or later
you got to reckon with yourself and
change right so then teach a person then
how to trade that emotion for an
elevated emotion now trade the emotion
for an elevated emotion right so you're
going to give that up and you're going
to practice feeling gratitude for as an
example yes the person says well I can't
feel gratitude and I say absolutely you
can because you don't practice feeling
it you practice spending most of your
time feeling hatred and frustration so
now it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened where it's
happening to you so the moment you open
your heart and you feel gratitude well
that emotion then is telling the body
that the experience has already occurred
and the thought then can make it into
the body because it's consistent with
the thought so now you're beginning to
program the autonomic nervous system
into a very specific Destiny you got to
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life if you're sitting
down and you start thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're Conjuring up in your mind and you
begin to feel the emotion of that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world our world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then they're they're
constantly reaffirming their emotional
states so when it comes time to give up
that emotion they can say I really want
to do it but really the body is stronger
than the mind because it's been
conditioned that way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt in suffering because at least
they can predict it being the unknown is
a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain and people say
to me well I can't predict my future
I'm in the unknown and I always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain what
behaviors do you want to demonstrate in
one day the act of rehearsing the
mentally closing your eyes and
rehearsing the action
they're rehearsing the reaction of what
you want or yeah the action of what you
want by closing your eyes and mentally
rehearsing some action if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between what you're Imaging
and what you're experiencing in 3D World
so then you begin to install the
neurological Hardware in your brain to
look like the event has already occurred
now your brain is no longer a record of
the past now it's a map to the Future
and if you keep doing it priming it that
way the hardware becomes a software
program and who knows you just may start
acting like a happy person I think
that we Define reality with our senses
and I think that is one of the biggest
Illusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind that your
brain has literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred now the
latest research in plasticity says
that's absolutely possible and can you
select a new possibility in the quantum
field and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future every single day to such a
degree that your body as the unconscious
mind the objective mind does not know
the difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to Signal new genes in new ways to
change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future that your body begins to
change to look like it's already
happened now this is where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it now it begins to come
to you you become the vortex for the
magnet to your destiny so then people
who come out of their meditation and
they say well I just focused on my
wealth why isn't it there well you're
not that good if you're asking why isn't
it there you're back to the old person
again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then see what kind of effects begin
to take place without moving into
impatience without moving into
frustration without starting to analyze
why it hasn't happened or when that is
the Trap of defining reality with your
senses so you have the thought of your
future and you don't see it then you
experience separation but people who are
practicing this work they have the
thought of their future and they feel
the emotion of their future they're
still connected to it right so that
takes practice and it's just learning
like hitting a golf ball hitting a
tennis ball dancing the salsa you know
crocheting whatever it is you gotta you
gotta start out staying real conscious
and learning then you get good at it and
gets to be instrumental gets to be fun
and that's that's what I want for
everybody that the Act of Creation
should be a blissful like ecstatic loose
free process and um and so
I love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future then
they're not living by the memories of
the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people the unknown is a
scary place so they don't see that
future because they're used to seeing
that future with evidence with their
senses and the you have to be able to
get beyond that and stay in the unknown
stay in that discomfort and then in that
moment to be begin to self-regulate like
oh I'm starting to feel a little anxiety
ooh I'm starting to feel a little
frustration that's the defining moment
where your body's going back to the past
because emotions are a record of the
past or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory and if you keep catching
yourself those victories add up and it's
not so much about your wealth or your
health or your freedom or your new
relationship
it's actually about who you become I'm
not the type of guy who sits in my house
meditating 24 hours a day and expect
things to come to me I'm a pragmatist
I'm a practical person I'm going to take
value and information I'm going to apply
it and see if I can gain more value from
it so the message is not to sit and
meditate and just receive Universal love
and do nothing else
because my message is to not disengage
in life but to fully engage in life
that's my message I think uh you know if
we everything starts with a thought I
mean everything that you do in your life
you you have to have a thought before
you initiate an action right so so if
you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny like
any great leader in history understands
that uh the first thing you have to do
is you have to decide are you going to
be defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning and
your brain is a record of the past it's
an artifact of everything you've learned
and experienced to this moment right
it's a it's a Memory Bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places and the
moment they start start turning on those
circuits those memories are actually
causing them to think in the past every
single one of those memories has an
emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences so then the moment they
recall the event or the they recall some
problem in their life they start feeling
unhappy they start feeling discouraged
they start feeling anxious now thoughts
of the language of the brain and
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future and so
what happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this your body is your unconscious mind
it doesn't know the difference between
an experience in your life that creates
an emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts and you can't think
greater than how you feel or feelings
have become the means of thinking you're
thinking in the past your lens of the
future is going to be colored by the
past so you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
yes enough to see well the challenge is
is that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts be begin to fire
certain circuits in your brain the nerve
cells that fire together wire together
so all of a sudden you start getting
hardwired and those are the thoughts
that you can think the easiest at the
same time those thoughts produce
chemicals called emotions and the next
thing you know your body gets accustomed
to living by the same emotions and it
could be guilt it could be unhappiness
it could be pain but at least it's
familiar to you at least you can predict
it so some people would rather cling to
The Familiar than take a chance in
possibility so for most people then they
say well
I don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change is starting
to think about what you've been thinking
about and change it and and then when
you begin to observe those thoughts
you're no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing yourself just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like letting a match in a dark
place so you feel uncomfortable so it's
easier to turn on your TV it's easier to
to play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well when
you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown then it begs
the question what thoughts do you want
to fire and wire in your brain because
your attention on those thoughts begins
to reorganize circuitry remold the brain
you have to really begin to
mentally rehearse like so you ask
yourself at the end of your day I do
this every day how'd I do how'd I do
today bro how'd you do did you do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could I involve my experience now
you may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go God the next time that
happens I think I'm going to do this or
I'm going to do that or I'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute I just
need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't fall
from grace they don't allow their energy
to drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say I had a
hard day yesterday at a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and I don't feel
like doing the work well that's the time
to get back on the horse yeah because
because it's the it's all of those times
that we self-correct those are the most
valuable moments thus people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else think
of your autonomic nervous system as the
automatic nervous system and I've been
saying for years that autonomic is
synonymous with automatic and it's that
part of our systems part of our nervous
system that functions behind the scenes
of our awareness and it regulates body
temperature and and hormones and blood
supply and blood sugar levels uh and it
and it happens without any uh of our
conscious mind
so in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one is the
sympathetic nervous system and its job
is for protection from threats and
dangers in our outer environment and
think of the sympathetic nervous system
as the gas pedal and when there's a
danger to the gross anatomy of the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses this system
is switched on automatically and once it
turns on there's a host of physiological
functions that begin to happen
automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources for that
threat or that danger to deal with it
and and when it's switched on uh we
don't go half in we go all the way in
because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive survive in a
threat or a danger in the outer
environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones
we're tapping the body's resources and
remobilizing all of its energy and
pupils dilate salivary juices shut off
respiratory rate increases heart rate
increases blood is sent to the
extremities glucose is mobilized the
immune system dials up and then it dials
down and all of these systems switching
on and and turning on is to be able to
allow the body to adapt to some threat
in the outer world and that is the gas
pedal and the sympathetic nervous system
or the fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run from the danger to fight uh and
stay or to freeze and hide and those are
the primary choices that we have created
in evolution
and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on and we as we've been saying
for very long for a very long time uh
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on the
other nervous system that branch of the
autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system and think
of that nervous system as the break or
the clutch this is where the body
conserves energy this is where utilizes
nutrients and and transports chemicals
to cells and Metabolism goes up and and
this is a time for growth this is a time
for repair this is a time for
restoration and there's a delicate
balance between the sympathetic nervous
system and the parasympathetic nervous
system and so then when you're feeling a
constant fear when you're feeling
constant anger or aggression when you're
feeling constant pain and suffering and
you're living by the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy for growth repair
restoration there's no energy for
long-term building projects so then when
you're feeling gratitude and your heart
is open you're broadcasting energy into
the field the frequency a frequency you
lay the intent of the thought of your
health or your wealth that frequency can
carry the thought of your wealth it can
carry the thought of your health if
you're suffering you can't the suffering
does not carry that energy does not
carry the thought of your wealth it
carries a different set of thoughts so
then so then we're teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated right
and you better know how to self-regulate
and you have to know the moment you
disconnect from the energy of your
future because of some circumstance in
your life and you lose that feeling if
you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change the the
frustration from some experience in your
life back to the energy of your future
now
that requires Great awareness and great
effort but if you have a commune of
people that are practicing this on a
daily basis and they're connected to
their future because that's where their
their mind is
um they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now Lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it for 45 minutes to an hour
it's a skill now they know that they
know how to do it so now they have brain
coherence and heart coherence well once
the heart begins to become orderly and
coherent it acts as an amplifier and it
drives energy to the brain so now the
brain is getting more energy once the
heart is open and then you're thinking
different set of thoughts and those
thoughts produce different chemicals for
you to feel more of that and here comes
nitric oxide from oxytocin and then all
of a sudden your heart literally starts
to swell it literally begins to open up
and there's more energy going there and
now you're coming from a different level
of Mind Crossing that River of change
from the old self to the new self
there's a neurological a biological
chemical hormonal a genetic death of the
old self but if you teach people there's
something on the other side they won't
give up on themselves they'll keep going
so there's enough evidence to encourage
people and you can't tell me you're too
old to do this work you can't tell me
you're too sick to do this work you
can't tell me you had a turbulent past
or or that you're too overweight or too
underweight or too out of shape or you
can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not 60 and if we do
a week-long event we got a thousand
people or 1500 people and they are all
in and that when they start getting
Beyond themselves that first day or
second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting
could you speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
[Music]
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no and the more we
remember the event the more we produce
the emotions that are associated with it
and we're conditioning the brain and
body further into the past yes or no yes
and it you keep doing it enough times
it's no longer conscious that you're
holding a grudge
it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person that's the lens
that we're perceiving reality are you
with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this we
all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere and no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy is
going to move Scott to it's going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion when you feel true true
kindness and care it's hard to hold the
grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still yeah so then from
a Quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic Bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and I let them
go
so then
forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them that's
all it is and when you start getting
happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin when you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work and
then you forgive and then you're like I
don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
and when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in
Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same life
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness most people are waiting for
their life to change yes so they can
feel gratitude to feel abundance to feel
whole you know that's the old model of
cause and effect you know so if you're
living with emptiness you're living with
lack you're living with pain most people
have been conditioned that something out
there has to take away this emptiness or
feeling inside of them but if you
believe that you're creating your life
and you're living by lack well lack
isn't going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually create wealth you
generate wealth you generate abundance
so the moment you start teaching your
body emotionally what that future is
going to feel like before it's made
manifest well your body is the
unconscious mind believes it's living in
that future in the present moment now
it's the scientific fact that it's the
environment that signals the gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion so when
you begin to embrace an elevated emotion
you're beginning to Signal the gene
ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key wow
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind so your personality
literally ad is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth if
you want another amazing joke that
spends a video check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there